um you know it's another interesting
stat so 50 of women over 30 are single
and childless it'd be really interesting
to see what percentage of them have had
abortions
do you know the number that would be i
don't know i wish i did i couldn't find
it
it would be better if you did that
but
based on the numbers you've caught
before i think you'll see those
97 or 98 of women who have had abortions
have had it more than no 42 42 have had
it before i've had it before so with
that is quite a high number
yeah so given that like you could
imagine that these women
in their 30s they have been sexually
active yeah so you can imagine that in
in those situations mistakes would have
happened right well and you'd also think
about
because the other half that's their
first abortion but will they come back
in the future so it's really i don't
know what the percentage would be if you
include like if we surveyed the same
group of women but i don't think they
they gather data like that yeah but i'll
be crazy to find out yeah
because they really
like again every girl that i know that's
had an abortion personally like they
were just irresponsible they weren't on
any form of birth control they're
sleeping with a guy they couldn't see a
future with
and then
it's it's the rolo tomasi says it's the
ultimate form of hypergamy shout out to
the goat
why do women do that they're like why no
i'm not saying all women do that let me
take that back but then it's like why do
some woman sleep it goes back to the
question of why are some women sleeping
with guys that they don't see a future
with like that came back to what you
said before earlier guys
guys are out here ignoring the red flags
like why are you ignoring the red flags
you're doing this to yourself type of
thing and then when it comes to the
point of going back to today's topic
abortion
i couldn't afford sympathy for you
because you put yourself in that
position so i think this is
there i think this starts it begins with
the family and the the nuclear family
has been under decrease for for years
now
so as you can see as the family starts
to break apart like to give an example
the reason why
um
a woman a guy would have to ask for
a father to marry his daughter is
because that guy would of the father
would often check is this man worthy of
my daughter does he have the right
characteristics of a man to raise the
brothers and the uncles you have the
brothers and the uncles as well but this
idea of oh i'm independent i can do it
alone i don't need a man men are traffic
etc etc just reinforces this these these
negative
aspects because i think women are quite
naive like you don't understand men to
the capacity that other men can
understand men and i also say that men
understand women then other women
understand themselves why because men
have to pursue women so we have to
understand how you behave in order to
successfully court and date and get
women so with that when you have
brothers and men in your life and you
ask them questions they will give you
objective answers to help you understand
the situation that you're in so like my
sisters for example they'd often come to
me and say that you know this boy is
making me feel this way like what's
going on and i can explain that to them
and i'm sure that that's helped them out
of countless
unnecessary situations it really does
like i i started telling my dad about
the guys i'd like go on dates with or
whatever and i would like i would just
give him stories and let's just explain
them to him and like guys are so
perceptive and they just understand men
quicker than we can 100 but it helps if
they listen they'll win it that's the
thing like that's the thing until you
actually like listen to what a guy is
saying and i've realized in my only
experience anyway like i think the only
women that actually understand men are
women that have had like many or more
brothers
or like you did you see what i'm saying
because it's like if you're forced to be
if you're forced to grow up with someone
like i i got two sisters you got two
sisters right and at one point i i was
living with my two sisters and my mom so
i got three women in the house so
i have no choice but to almost
understand women because it's like
why is she getting emotional why is she
like this what do you do so i go i gotta
force myself you know no it's
interesting you say that because i
always say i can tell the difference a
lot of times between girls that grow up
with brothers and group of sisters
what do you think the difference is
it's um i've just noticed girls that
grow up with brothers often are like
more tomboy less drama a bit more going
to certain situations yeah people are
aware
yeah
yeah i mean i'm not not always i'm not
saying i get it 100 of the time but
um and then it's interesting you say
that because i grew up with five
brothers so it's like
your family's like a foot what's your
name
it's a bunch of tall gingers yeah
so another thing so
in 2017 northern ireland
funding scheme introduced to provide
funded abortions in england whales and
whales for residents of northern ireland
in cases of hardships travel costs are
also covered funding is provided by the
government equalities office and hm
treasury
do you guys think that we should be
publicly funding abortions no no no
publicly yeah that's that's just like
the easy way out you know they see that
they're like oh it's free anyways let's
just go yeah my travels covered
it's covered this is interesting because
you're pro-choice and you still agree
that it shouldn't be publicly funded it
shouldn't be my my answers are changing
now like as i'm getting educated yeah
but like
yeah no it should not be publicly funded
no i agree because like why do i have to
pay for her bad yeah
i have to pay for that no it's like what
paul was telling me exactly what paul
was telling me earlier like
you decided to sleep in bed at 2 a.m in
the morning with this guy why am i now
paying for what you decided to do me i
was sleeping at 2 a.m you you decided to
go be with me look what i put you look
what it put me i've got a good night's
rest you're just panicking about your
future that's the difference
like
so why do me and you are not the same
i'm sleeping and you're there panicking
oh my gosh i'm pregnant without dude no
take it back two weeks ago what was you
doing at 2am in the morning exactly so
you got yourself to fend for that and on
the topic of
should it be publicly funded no we
shouldn't because once you give
something free free free to the public
they're abusive
so
it's interesting because i was looking
at the numbers so abortion numbers
england and wales from 2010 to 2020. um
ish can you pull up the it's the
second
no it's the first link in the google doc
um and if you scroll down go to
figure 2.1
go down scroll down yeah scroll down
it should
two key points in 2020.
oh do you see that yeah so when
nhs made um abortions publicly funded
you see in 2016 it was 190 000 abortions
per year it's
that like 220 215 thousand so you see
that's just abused isn't it like yeah
so that's like specifically when they
made it publicly funded that skyrocketed
so in 2016 they made it publicly funded
yeah okay you can see the skyrocketing
yeah
that's the kind of thing that makes you
start fingers conspiracies are real in
terms of population control
this is okay this is what we're gonna
this next part okay
so
in and this is the next part that i was
going to talk about so in the u.s one of
the number one abortion providers is do
you guys know what it is is it the
government planned parenthood oh wow
so planned parenthood it's one of the
number one abortion providers in the u.s
and
i wish i had an american on the panel
because they would know how big planned
parenthood is like there's a really big
fight on whether the government should
be able to fund planned parenthood
because planned parenthood is the number
one abortion provider in the us
so um
margaret sanger was the one who
founded planned parenthood in the early
like
actually i don't know when it was i
think the early 1900s but she was a
eugenicist
okay so she believed like that whites
were the inferior race
inferior
oh wait superior
sorry sorry they she believed that
white's for the superior race and
basically the black population in the us
would be double today if it weren't for
planned parenthood because the planned
parenthood disproportionately provides
abortions to the black community so much
so that there
it's almost 50 of black births are
aborted it's 474 per 1000
live births and 80 even to this day 80
of planned parenthoods are in minority
neighborhoods
and there's no outcry
i'm i'm not surprised by that statistic
to be honest
i'm not surprised i agree and the tits
are just there like we can't argue with
that so i'm gonna i'm gonna read um an
excerpt from it's like two paragraphs
when it they talked about
i can't remember the name of the
document i got this from but margaret
singer founder of the american birth
control movement was a leading
spokesperson and activist in pro
in promotion of controlling the birth
rates among blacks and others she
considered genetically inferior an avid
supporter of eugenics saenger became a
formidable force when pushing her
project designed to employ black leaders
to promote first birth control and later
abortion as viable options for family
planning she favor she
favored the mal illusion branch of
eugenics frequently saying the genetic
makeup
or of poor and minorities for example
was inferior sanger believed that it was
necessary to reduce the birth rate among
the disease the sickly the poverty
stricken and the anti-social classes
elements unable to provide carrying for
themselves and the burden of which we're
all forced to carry paying black staff
members into the six figures planned
parenthood and other abortion supporters
have banned their advocates across the
black community spouting a deceptive yet
unified message of the lack of access to
quality health care supported by funds
provided through